I think morality is good for civil
coexistence but morality alone will not
save this society unless we develop an
accountability to our Creator not merely
for moral reasoning but for the
recognition that life at its core is
sacred
[Music]
hello and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special our special
guest today is Ravi Zacharias he's
author of over 25 books his newest book
is the logic of God he's a cultural
apologist on behalf of judeo-christian
values
Ravi thanks so much for joining the show
you may be the guest most requested by
our audience so I'm very excited to have
you here thanks for making the time must
have been my family well I want to jump
right in because there's there's a lot I
want to cover with you and why don't we
start with this you're obviously one of
the most prolific debaters when it comes
to religion and the presence of God in
the universe
they've debated a bunch of folks on the
on the secular atheist side who's the
toughest debate you've ever had in terms
of well you know in the earlier days I
remember doing a couple of debates
courtesy of Emory University and so on
and overseas I debated some Islamic
scholars in the city of Hyderabad and
Hindu scholars as well I moved away from
the debating format been years ago
because I really felt it was nowhere
near as effective as an open forum is
where you give the privilege of the
audience to ask you the questions and
give them the opportunity to challenge
what it is you're saying otherwise
you're putting one intellect against
another and whoever has read one more
book can do better on the whole thing
provided they've got the eloquence on
their side so I think the toughest
debaters to deal with are those of
contrary religious worldviews where the
animus becomes very intense and where
the audience can be more provocative
I've done dialogues of that nature
no really difficult question been over
the years of nearly 46 years of
traveling this globe this the questions
are the same although the relevance of
issues has changed a little bit so I
would say a religious counter
perspectives especially of a
monotheistic a stripe they become tough
because you're navigating very carefully
one wrong word and that has now shifted
into the open forum model where you're
asked questions but which are pretty
point-blank but you're not necessarily
given the privilege of a dissenting view
while they themselves would call for the
freedom of choice
on all views so that would be my answer
to your question
I feel the tough ones are those who
believe in absolutes but from a
different transcendent perspective you
know what you've answered you know
thousands and thousands of questions
from members of the audience what's the
question that you receive most often
when you do your events well you deal
with it very much in your own book which
by the way I should say one of the
finest I have read I need to go back to
it I was reading it as I was preparing
to come here what an amazing sweep of
sensitive knowledge and I'm saying that
God has given to you you know I think it
ought to be required reading University
professors have the courage to do it but
as I look and so do these navigational
things the two toughest questions to me
you know once upon a time the
cosmological the teleological and all of
these ontological arguments were richly
debated on the campus but now there are
more culturally sensitive issues that
are raised however the one thorn in the
side of the theistic framework is the
problem of evil the problem of pain the
problem of suffering and I think what
someone once said virtue in distress and
vice in triumph has made atheists of
mankind I think it's the most real
question frankly many of the
philosophers who ultimately David Hume
himself you know did away with the
notion of a sovereign force cause for
them this was the thorny question so to
me how can an all-powerful and an all
sovereign God and an all good God allow
so much of pain and suffering in this
world I think it's a legitimate question
but that's the one today it's much more
cultural issues so many things that
you've dealt with
I think the relevance of a moral law
that crisps judeo-christian worldview
invokes that we are not just because
intended to reason but reason morally of
that those are the debates I think the
two issues and I think they are
connected so let's talk about the
problem of suffering and painting
obviously there have been a bunch of
religious thinkers
taking this on it's always puzzling to
me when you hear secular humanists and
atheists suggest that it's a revelation
that this is a problem for religious
thought obviously a problem for
religious thought since the very
beginning what do you think is the is
the best answer to that very difficult
question well you know job is the one
who wrestled with it the most job to me
came up with a very incredible answer
and that's to me a softer touch today
but I think a profound touch for those
of us who have that knowledge of God to
him when he said I had heard of you by
the hearing of my ear now I see have
seen you I abhorred myself and I'm
horrified and he repented that
relationship with God same as with the
Habakkuk you know they struggled with
these issues but that divine encounter
gave them as pair of eyes so that they
could see to the problem from a very
different perspective
God is God acts God changes that's what
Habakkuk came up with you know the
actuality of God and distinction to
atheism the eventualities of his working
and distinction 2d ISM and the
eternality of this perspective and
distinct into the pantheism so the
question itself is well answered within
the judeo-christian worldview but I
think as a culturally relevant apologist
this is the way I deal with it then and
I found it to be quite effective because
the breath wheels start turning I was
the University of Nottingham years ago
when it was first thrown at me and a guy
stood up and he just said how can you
possibly talk of a good god of goodness
when there's so much evil in this world
how can you talk about a God that
actually exists in this kind of evil and
this kind of suffering that of course
Richard Dawkins and all of them raises
him so I looked at him and I said let me
ask you this you're talking about evil
he said yes I said when you say this
evilly aren't you assuming that such a
thing is good he said yes
I said when you say this such a thing is
good aren't you assuming this such a
thing as a moral law by which to
distinguish between good and evil he
paused for a moment on that one and then
I referenced him to Bertrand Russell's
debate with coppleson in which coppleson
looked at
rustle and said to him how do you
differentiate be good and bad and
Russell said the same we are
differentiate between blue and green and
Collison said but wait a minute you
differentiate between those colors by
seeing don't you he said yes he said how
do you differentiate between good and
bad mr. Russell he paused and he said on
the basis of my feeling what else I
think that was the weakest point of
Russell's debate so when I looked at him
he said all right I will agree to you
that there is a moral law the basis of
which differentiate between graver
I said evil therefore good good
therefore a moral law the basis of which
to differentiate between good Engel I
said but if you posit a moral law you
must pause it a moral lawgiver
but that's whom you are trying to
disprove and not prove your whole point
is invoking a moral law you which you
cannot invoke without a moral lawgiver
so your problem of evil actually
disappears with the false assumptions
that you're making you know Ben he
paused and he looked at me and he said
what then am I asking you
I was with William Lane Craig whom you
had on your program William Lane Craig
and I were on our program with a
physicist by the name of Bernard lichen
and pantheous Purnima jitinder mohanty
sponsored by every emory university
years ago and this was thrown back at me
why do you need to posit a moral
lawgiver all right will grant you there
is this abstract moral law why do you
need to post a moral lawgiver and my
answer is this then every time the
problem of evil is raised it is either
raised by a person or about a person
which means the questioner assumes
persons have intrinsic worth and that is
an assumption they cannot make in a
random evolutionary universe with no
primary mind and personal being as our
Creator so if we have the random
collocation of atoms how do we attribute
essential worth to ourselves so the
person component is vital to the
question and so the moral law needs a
moral lawgiver if persons are to have
essential worth so to me the problem of
evil when it is raised is a self stock
defying problem because it has to assume
a framework that it cannot
to itself in a random universe without
personal value so how do we get from the
idea of the the moral lawgiver and a God
who is present in the universe to what
exactly that moral law is so there's
sort of the God of the Philosopher's
this is obviously puzzled a lot of
religious philosophers
there's the God of the Philosopher's the
sort of unmoved mover the the being that
that generates a unity to the universe
and in order to the universe how does
that translate over into the sort of
moral law that we practice or that we
should practice can you just do all of
this on the basis of reason alone just
looking at the universe through natural
law or do you need something like
revelation I think that's a great
question and your book I think you've
brilliantly given that dialectic of your
you know reason and purpose and meaning
they are inextricably bound and you
really cannot have one without the other
the way we get to it is something like
this I do two frameworks on this man as
an apologist dealing with the
judeo-christian worldview we all need to
know the truth
ultimately we are in search for the
truth you know where we need to accept
the fact but what how do we get to the
truth and philosophers of old have told
us as the correspondence theory of truth
and the coherence theory of truth
correspondence applies to particular
statements coherence applies to a
cumulative presentation of those
statements so when you go to a court of
law the correspondence and coherence
theory are always brought to bear in
determining guilt or innocence but how
do we get to it
I say there are three ways of logical
consistency empirical adequacy and
experiencial relevance is my argument
logically consistent is there any
empirical basis for me to believe what I
am believing and is there any experience
or relevance to all of this but then
this has to be applied to the four
questions of life origin meaning
morality and destiny where do I come
from what is my life really mean how do
i distinguish between good and evil what
happens to human being when he or she
dies that closing chapter in your
conversation with your daughter is
brilliant you know the question of
eternality even comes into the mind of a
little one there's that intuitive drive
towards that origin meaning morality and
destiny pursuit truth correspondence
coherence logical consistency empirical
adequacy exponential relevance when you
form a worldview these are the four
questions you have to answer by applying
the notions of truth so with the moment
you say the word revelation you know
this is one of those dinosaurs who
actually believes a book dropped out of
heaven and so on and so forth it's not
as simplistic as that you take the
revelation of God that has come across a
millennium and a half of Revelation you
apply these tests and you see that the
existence of God presents a framework
for the existentially undeniable
questions that we struggle with those
very questions are legitimized because
of the value that we later claim so yes
there's reason and revelation but not
some kind of pie in the sky by and by
but propositional truth that is put to
the test by a scrutinizing mind and the
jarir biblia the judeo-christian
worldview been I believe I was raised in
a counterculture to this I wasn't raised
in either of those worldviews I was a
naturalist I was a skeptic and I ended
up on a bed of suicide when I was 17
years old desperately looking for the
very thing your book talks about you
know that individual value and that
individual purpose and a belongingness
to a community and so on and it was then
when the Bible I could even hold the
Bible by the way because I was my body
was dehydrated I had taken some poison
that emptied me of all the water
moisture in my body and then to see how
God through the flow of history and of
course even though we have our
differences we have a common background
in communion with God both of us have
that goal and in the person of Jesus
Christ I found that answer and so my
relationship to the person of God as Joe
pointed out as Habakkuk pointed out that
relationship is key because some answers
to life transcend
the propositional nature of things they
don't violate it but they transcend it
so I think you get to the answer of who
God is not just by some leap of faith
which we sometimes attribute to people
mine was a very recent study of
scriptures and the reasoning that we
applied was a rational type but the
importance was there was a moral
reasoning behind the whole process so
you don't just get to it by either
reason or revelation it's a confluence
of both in proper balance so in a second
I wanna ask you about the nature of the
moral law what has it evolved which part
of it has not which part of it is
eternal which part of it is is evolving
due to human reason I'm gonna ask you
about that in just one second but first
no one really has time to go to the post
office you're busy who's got time for
all that traffic parking lugging all the
mail and packages
it is a real hassle particularly in Los
Angeles where if you park in a red zone
for more than five seconds they'll give
you a ticket I know it's happened to me
this is why you need stamps calm it's
one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps common
luminate strips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online sellers shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle all of this stuff
with ease simply use your computer to
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it there's a
reason I use stamps comma and my company
uses stamps calm once your mail is ready
you just hand it over to your mail
carrier or you drop it in the mailbox it
is that simple with stamps calm you have
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40% off Priority Mail so this is a
no-brainer stamps calm it saves you time
and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses use stamps calm right now my
listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long term
commitment just go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter Shapiro so when we talk about
the judeo-christian moral law one of the
questions that I get from folks like Sam
Harris or like Michael Shermer is all
right let's assume that there is this
this eternal moral law that corresponds
with some form of
truth and a lawgiver so why has that law
evolved over time so to take for example
the example that they like best is
slavery so originally the Bible
contemplates that slavery is part of
life and then over time we've decided
that not only is slavery a part not a
part of life slavery is a grave evil
that ought to be fought wherever it
exists how did how do we justify
evolution in the judeo-christian
framework of morality well it's of
course the metaphysical extrapolation of
the naturalistic interpretation of the
very origin of life so when you talk
about the evolution of humanity itself
they want to talk about morality itself
also sort of evolving I think it becomes
a circular argument
the argument that somehow we were
valueless to start with and just happen
to be on this radar screen of time and
that we developed all these things over
a period of time I think is a false view
of the beginnings in fact though you
know very well as a scholar within the
Jewish framework the very concept of
slavery a very different very different
idea of what we interpret as what
slavery is all about and them and you
talk about Paul talking about how to
treat the quote slave in the household
and that he was willing to be there
present and even redeem this person in a
socio-economic framework that you have
these kinds of terms used and and
systems used we are bound to make
blunders so then I would turn the
question on it said and say all right if
you believe that we have evolved more
morally why is it in the 20th century
that we killed more people in warfare
than all of the previous 19th centuries
put together so it is not an honest
representation of how we have actually
come into believing in moral framework
in fact there are some things now that
we have reversed over 5,000 years of
civilized history for thousands of years
some people never believed some of the
things that we have begun to believe so
I would say that to me the most
important phrase been
in the ten commandments I don't believe
there's a better moral framework that
starts with the very being of God and
all the way to my to the sacredness of
my life my neighbor's life my neighbor's
marriage my neighbor's property I mean
this goes back you know to 3500 years
ago the most important phrase to me been
in that is I am the Lord your God that
brought you out of the land of Egypt
that Redemption is prior to
righteousness and then righteousness
leads on to worship so when you get to
Exodus 20 and you're dealing with that
beautiful moral law and then you move
five chapters later and you move into
the tabernacle and the framework of
reference I think it is the change of
heart that is the only answer to the
moral framework and here's the scary
thing God did not send us his message to
make bad people good morality alone
we'll never save us sometimes in the
name of morality people have done some
horrible things it is the fact that the
heart is in need of redemption in need
of forgiveness and it is redemption that
must precede righteousness so to talk
about morality having been involved when
you go back 3500 years ago and the moral
law is given to us it was because people
had already violated that relationship
with God so I say him as far from
morality evolving right from the
beginning we have known what it was all
about so what happens in the first three
chapters of Genesis happens in this
world every day what happened in the
Temptation saga Ben I think is very
critical and your book points out what
has happened as a result of this flow
okay in the day that you eat of the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil you
will die that's the word of God but the
enemy of our souls comes as our our you
will be as God knowing good and evil
that has been the battle from millennia
what is the battle to allow God
be God ought to play God and in the
defining good of it and what happened
when they are confronted I didn't know
any of it I didn't the serpent this idea
of violating the authority of God and
becoming autonomous and then blaming
everything else this is not evolved this
goes back over three millennia wrong and
we have challenged it every day in this
victim culture what are we doing
so my fault it's this person's fault we
don't believe in absolutes
we have autonomy so on the one hand we
came to be autonomous but when we go
wrong we blame somebody else as someone
else enormous so I do not accept this
idea that it is some somehow evolved you
go back millennia ago and you see the
value of human life and the value of a
moral law millennia back so in your
worldview do you make a distinction
between that which is sinful and that
what you consider immoral so this is a
sort of deep philosophical issue in the
religious community is there a
difference between doing something that
the Bible considers sinful and doing
something that is moral on some sort of
naturalistic level the difference
between hurting somebody else and for
example engaging in a consensual
behavior there's obviously take a modern
example engaging a consensual behavior
that doesn't hurt a third party per se
but may be a sin against the natural law
or a sin against the Bible I think sin
is a vertical term it is not merely a
horizontal term when David sent with
what happened with Bathsheba and he
falls on his face before God in Psalm 51
what does he say against you and you
only have I sinned and done this evil in
your sight
Nathan confronted him sinned as a
vertical thing morality can very easily
become a horizontal term and I think
this is where we are getting grounded
literally and figuratively Ben when we
only talk about a moral framework if you
go to India today moral reasoning is
very different to that of say the moral
reasoning of the West and sin to me is a
violation not of something ABS
tract is a violation of a personal
command there is no sin in God that
means there's no contradiction in God
God is a self existent being it is
impossible for him not to exist he
exists eternally so if I am to be in
keeping with that will of my Heavenly
Father when the prodigal son returned
what does he say I've sinned against
heaven and against you in that order we
take the vertical and make it horizontal
and you know our morals truly these days
Bend to me which is very deep by the way
and if I may just digress for just a
moment I'm moving the first time I came
to the West Coast it was in the 70s okay
I was an undergraduate in Toronto at
that time and I have to say to you
yesterday as I walked through Los
Angeles this state is a microcosm of the
collision course in which we are headed
culturally probably one of the most
beautiful States anywhere in the world
it's got the mountains the oceans got
the deserts finest minds in this country
from cyber capacity to artistic splendor
all of this and yet what did I see
yesterday as I walked if you're taking
me back to Calcutta 40 50 years ago I
would have been walking past many
homeless and thinking to myself how
we're gonna solve this problem so what
we have done in debunking the notion of
sin and talking merely morality we have
ended up with a dead end word that
people really cannot relate to in fact
if you want to end a discussion with the
press reporter just use the word sin and
you know that's it
that's why frankly I like what you've
done in your book to me when I'm talking
to a person and they say to me what do
you think is wrong then I say it's a
violation of purpose we have violated
the purpose for which we have created
they can connect much more with that
existing show rub and then of course
they look at you and say what I mean by
Valley
of purpose I see if you take a car and
Juran amok in a crowd of people and kill
them can you blend General Motors for it
some more say that's not why I fashioned
this car twist for transportation so
we've run amok and what we have done
with our values and then we blame the
creator for it so I think morality is
good for civil coexistence what Calvin
have talked about the fourth use of a
long type thing but morality alone will
not save this society unless we develop
an accountability to our Creator not
merely for moral reasoning but for the
recognition that life at its core is
sacred the D SEC realization of life is
at the core of what has happened we do
not know what it means to be human and
in losing that definition as Chesterton
would say we wear our feet firmly
planted in midair so when we look at the
role of government in all this there's a
really interesting debate that's broken
out in the conservative movement right
now between one wing that's more
libertarian and I will admit I'm in this
wing that the wing that still defense
class classical liberalism and a sort of
fusion ISM the idea that rights are
important and rights are important
because we have duties that there's a
then that duties are to impose socially
but not necessarily by government and
then there is a group of folks on the
right who argue in convincing fashion
that liberalism may in fact be part of
the problem that if you have a liberal
free society this grants the ability for
people who oppose traditional morality
to tear down the structure to tear away
at community that the individualism that
is integrally connected to liberalism
that that individual is in tears away at
a lot of the same communal values and so
you what you end up with is an atomistic
society in which there is no community
no common moral fabric you end up with
the rights without any of the duties and
that eventually ends in exactly what
you're talking about sort of breakdown
of society so where do you think the
proper role of government is in either
enforcing morality or not enforcing
morality what has to be done socially
and what can the government be
encouraging or should have been
encouraging and that's the tough
question of our time but what I know
more for greater certainty what they
ought not to be doing
and then we can move to what we can be
doing you know when you think of
liberalism
and our conservatism it all depends on
where you're talking you know if I'm
talking to the mullahs in Iran may the
heavens preserve us from that kind of
conservatism you know it's a demagogic
conservatism that has not even
understood what respect is for people of
dissenting opinions so I often put it
this way been in sort of right and left
we need to be thinking up and down I
remember talking to a former governor
and Senator and I was actually in
Washington meeting one of the people who
meets with more leaders around the globe
than anybody else and I just finished
meeting with him okay few minutes and
then I went talk to my wife and I having
doughnuts and coffee with this gentleman
I'll never forget what he said I won't
quote his name but he looked at my wife
and me and he said there's one word
that's dividing us here on Capitol Hill
just one word he said that word is God
if God exists or doesn't exist if God
doesn't exist Ben then the storms
liberal and conservative actually become
purely pragmatic words you know you look
at what happened in sunder Stalin's
Russia he was a believer in God at one
time seminary student and he clenched
his fist towards the heavens which was
literally the last gesture before he
died his daughter and other standing
from him clenched his fist towards the
heavens one more time threw his head
back on the pillow and he was gone
having taken the lives of 15 million of
his own people I remember telling this
story to a Russian general in Moscow and
during the days of the Cold War and the
tears were running down his face I said
is that what you want so the term right
and left there meant something
completely different but to the point of
your question here we at least have to
agree on one definition and until that
we will not progress what does it mean
to be human are we just on a grade and a
higher
a better animal or are we something
essentially different until I answer
that question it cannot answer my
question on why marital fidelity is
important why I need to be a good father
why need to be a good citizen I think
you've touched a little bit of this in
your book in talking about what good
citizenship
actually means and I think you go back
to the Socratic description and all you
know you've got the person who just
thinks in autonomous ly the idiot you
think of the others who think tribally
their small group and then you think of
who is a good citizen the one who is a
good citizen is willing to prickly
accept the value of every human life and
even to coexist in different worldviews
we took secularization evicted God then
we faced pluralism and pluralization and
we took it to mean relativism and then
we went to privatization where we used
to be at all that faith should be made
private so the key to me is redefining
whether secularism is really at the core
of what our government should be or
where we honor the fact of our founding
fathers that this was made for a moral
people this was made for those who had
the freedom to believe you privatize
faith you will ultimately privatize
morality and you will then publicize the
destruction of one another the whole key
to me is our we are circularly conscious
people or is there a transcendent
framework of value for me and you with
all of our differences that we can
cordially sit back and even agree to
disagree and give each other a hug and
say hey man here we go
can I say one more point to this
footnote and I'll tell you what the
mistake is the two words egalitarian ISM
and elitism egalitarianism bringing
quality we are meant to be as human
beings having that egalitarian right all
human beings are created equal elitism
but we do not believe all ideas are
equal some ideas are superior to other
ideas naturalistic frame
has ended up reversing this in our time
we have made an elitism of people and an
egalitarian ism of ideas and that has
put us on a collision course and so the
elitists will tell us whether our ideas
are good or not that's reverse I have to
respect a person made imago day but I
can say to them your ideas and mine are
not the same let's reason them through
and see why that D gala terrenal a
distension is attention with which we
are living having traversed the poles of
the current and short-circuiting life I
talk with a lot of college students just
the way you do and many of them ask the
question you know yeah is your
suggestion when you talk about religion
there can't be a good a theist or a good
secular person I always say well I don't
know a single religious person who
believes there can't be a secular person
who acts well and acts in concert with
with public morality it's a silly
question but it does raise the the
secondary question which is okay well if
I'm a good secular person I don't
believe in God but I still abide by a
certain level of morality what makes God
necessary to my life why should I think
about God as opposed to just sort of
behaving in the way that we all sort of
agree commonly is good I think it's a
great question but it hangs on the peg
of one flaw and that peg says autonomy
is all that really matters being
autonomous that I'm a law unto myself
first of all your your disclaimer is
very valuable I believe there are many
good people that I have met or skeptics
who are non-believers in God sometimes
they put us Christians to shame you know
one day when I see some of the courtesy
and the generosity of some of them well
received but the fact of the matter is
they are using a word that is only self
referencing Lea defined I am a good
person how do I decide that and if I am
only going upon my own reason you know
in some cultures they love their
neighbors and other cultures they eat
them both of them may think that they
are good and that they are doing good
think of what we are doing today while
considering ourselves a good
culture it is unthinkable some of the
decisions we are making at the highest
level of lawmakers and yet we call
ourselves good it is not a self-defining
motive first of all if I believe
goodness is purely on my definition I
have to give that prerogative to every
other human being even the naturalistic
framework of Immanuel Kant you know the
universalizing of a principle would
apply right here but the fact of the
matter is what I am a cross-cultural
person okay even within India I was
raised in the north born in the south
the color tension been the tension
between the complexions of people while
I was growing up I come from the south
so I'm darker complexion but I moved to
the north it was tough and in some parts
of India that is still so and you see
the matrimonial column wanting to marry
a wheat complexioned whatever that means
you know I my brother used to say is
this a whole wheat or what we're talking
about our chili we've got all these
tensions that go on so cultures have
different values in self-referencing
behavior once upon a time the subtle
system in India thank God it was
abolished every you know whether wife
had to burn herself on the pyre of a
husband so they thought have been good
people so to say I am good is a highly
risky statement if you do not believe in
absolutes
it is a relativistic term and if you say
all truth is relative then it is a
self-destructing statement
it destroys itself is it an absolute or
is that statement relative to so I say
yes many good people people who are
skeptics and have done wonderful things
in this world but to give oneself the
prerogative of a defining good leads to
a world of chaos so that is given
everywhere else and shows here's what I
say America talks a lot about rights but
we have not yet defined what is right my
rights stand on the bedrock of an
absolute
definition of what is right and it was
that's why people like bill before said
others were on the forefront of fighting
slavery because it was a wrong nobody
had the right to inflict that on any
human being so that's that's my answer
my answer is that there are good people
but they're living beyond the foundation
on which their lives are standing so
let's talk for a second about right so
you mentioned rights there and obviously
there's been a lot of talk the United
States is very ensconced and a lot of
rights talk there are a lot of thinkers
who have been very critical of this
there's a book called after virtue by
Alistair McIntyre and what she talks
about the the movement of rights beyond
sort of its natural law basis and the
counter reaction from the folks on the
secular humanist left to conservatives
has been well what you actually want is
a theocracy you guys define right you
say that there is a right so where are
you getting this idea that there is a
right to do wrong what is it right
except the right to occasionally do
something wrong or do something with
which we disagree if you truly believe
in a judeo-christian framework why not
cram that down on everybody else and
that's what a lot of secular humanists
attribute to religious people it is a
desire to do that from the top down so
let's ask that basic question what is
the value of Rights if you do know
what's right and I think MacIntyre does
a good job even in some of the titles of
his books you know whose justice what
morality those kinds of things that he
brings out and was writing prolifically
and several others yaki was another one
of those authors in this whole area of
ethical reasoning first of all I think
anyone who enforces a religious
worldview upon another one is probably
in belief of a very ignoble worldview
because God Himself gave us one of the
greatest gifts we have been for you and
me the freedom to believe and the
freedom to disbelieve but one thing he
did not give us was to disconnect the
entailments of those two options he gave
me the freedom to believe but gave me
the logical outworking of what will
happen and the freedom to disbelieve in
the logical outworking of how what will
happen I think
the fact is this concern has been
violated by the critic of the theistic
ideas rather than by the defenders you
know it better than most people here go
into a university campus today and who
has to go in with high security and high
protection okay it is those who want to
talk about the rights that we all really
have but we have a conservative view of
life those who don't believe in that
test framework they are not coming with
protection because they are not being
marked they are being listened to very
carefully so enforcement of any kind of
belief is not in keeping with the mercy
and the grace of God himself you know
there's a guy whom I won't name who is
violently opposed to any proclamation of
the judeo-christian worldview on
military bases okay so he founded this
organization and fights anybody who
wants to come and speak at military base
I've spoken at all of them are not
spoken at one at the Air Force Academy
so I went to see this guy I visited him
in his home city and had two big German
Shepherd dogs on either side of him you
know and then he looked at me and said
they like you I said I wish I could say
the feelings are mutual
he started discussing but you know he I
said what do you I said to him to me you
in my conversation I said forget what
you have against whistie Anna day and
you've written a lot about her so what
do you have against Jesus what do you
have against God he said because he
holds a gun to your head and tells you
you either believe or else I said that's
strange
isn't that what you're doing on the
Military Academy campuses you hold a gun
to their head and say if you don't do
what I'm telling you to I'm gonna take
it a court of law and ruin your family
order I said you got it wrong I said God
doesn't do that he is the one who tells
you he gives you the privilege of your
freedom to disbelieve I said you are
under estimating the Intel
Soviet military academies in thinking
those cadets sitting in front of me
don't have the intelligence enough to
make up their own minds after we have
presented our talks and an open forum
why do you think they are that dumb then
are you sending them to defend the whole
nation when you think they can't do and
make the different a decision of such a
do you know what he looked at me he said
I like you he took me out for a lunch
came to visit me in Atlanta along with
his wife and he said I will never stand
in your way again you can go to any one
of these and I'm about to go to miss
Martin and do it for him there so I
think we have to rationally and
courteously talk if civility goes out of
the marketplace Ben then what we've got
is violence at the most sophisticated
levels of the freedom so I as I look at
our society and say am i forcing you to
believe what I'm saying not one bit we
give you the freedom to reject but let's
at least be civil in the process now
here's what I say to the staunch skeptic
if you really want the next generation
to carry on the values to live and let
live and to have the courtesy of truly
allowing those who come into our shores
to be given respect no matter what their
belief system is then you better believe
that our moral values had have an
absolute mess of you truly believe in
relativism the America as you know it is
finished and the truth is that they
don't actually believe in relativism
even the ones who purport to believe in
relativism because they still suggest
that their value system is the highest
obviously it's a self-defeating
proposition but this does raise another
question that that you see very often in
the debate between religious and and
non-religious and that is the the debate
over free will so you mentioned that the
religious worldview takes into account
the idea that you're given the choice
the Deuteronomy says that you're
choosing here between life and death and
you're enjoined to choose life but
that's a recommendation not not a
compulsion the there is a new breed of
thought that I find may be the most
dangerous of any of the breeds of
thought and that is the outgrowth of a
full-on scientific naturalism scientism
the idea that we don't have free will
that effectively we are just a cluster
of cells moving meaningless
meaninglessly through the universe to
support this proposition what you see a
lot of the advocates doing is appealing
to scientific experiments
the lab at experiment the experiments
that suggest for example that you that
your brain is is activating before you
even know what you're thinking you're
not making a conscious decision that
effectively you are just a series of
firing neurons that thinks that you are
will than the sort of Spinoza phrase how
do you respond to accusations that human
beings there there is no truly innate
value to human beings basically were
just a piece of meat that has some
firing electrical neurons well I would
just ask him a simple question is what
you're saying true or purely determined
you know is this just a neurons firing
that I made you come to this conclusion
or do you actually believe they're not
activated to it that transcends everyone
else's objectivity it's a it's a
wonderful backdoor exit for taking human
responsibility how do why do we even
have our courts then they're just
they're just you know firing neurons
they are behaving by predetermined ways
about a month ago I was in the most
dangerous prison what used to be the
most dangerous prison in America the
Angola prison in Louisiana this is my
third visit they have nearly six
thousand prisoners and eighty-five
percent of them are on life without
parole pretty hard laws on there and we
were walking past every cell in death
row it's a very sobering thing been I'm
sure you've been to places like that one
tiny little almost just an exaggerated
cage really a toilet a bed in a table
and I'm talking to one man he puts his
hands through he had been there already
for 18 years and he asked me to pray for
him they read that's all they can do
they read books and then I heard the
voice ringing forth through the corridor
Amazing Grace how sweet the sound that
saved a wretch like me I once was lost
but now I'm found was blind but now I
see I looked over in the guard there was
wiping the tears away ok so three or
four of us walk over towards him
and I look at him and he is bellowing
this thing out of fine beautiful
african-american voice you know powerful
poor guy all races are represented there
the first guy I met was from the white
race 18 years waiting on death row in
disguise singing that song so I said how
long have you been here had been there
so many or 20 years his bed was covered
with crosses simple twine across wound
with rubber twine and I said to him are
you making those he said yes sir and he
gave me two of them and then he said I'm
also paint in this and he gave me a
spanking I asked him how he was doing
and the whole story of the redemption
that he found being then by the way dead
man walking was filled filmed right
there had him go up and looking at his
eyes
I was broken inside I said what went
wrong with this life how did it go wrong
but here in every cell is a Bible and
last time I went one of them said to me
if this Bible had been in my high school
it probably would not have been needed
here in my cell what a story
and what were his neurons firing them
his transformation also just
predetermined or is it something we
applaud and say this man is now free to
truly walk out after being freed from
his inner slave so this sense of
determinism yard goes back do you know
BF Skinner and some of these others who
came out in this 70s it was just another
backdoor escape to justify that we are
the way we are if that is true that we
ought not to be mocking anyone who
believes to the contrary because they
till are predetermined to wire that way
the moment you make a hierarchy of the
ways you no longer believe in
determinism you believe in an
objectivity on the basis of which to
define somebody's subjective response I
mean one of the things that I always
find ironic about this particular
argument is that people seem to exempt
themselves it's all - everybody else is
predetermined when it comes to me I
wrote this book it was it was I who
created this popular it's it's it never
applies inwardly okay so let's talk
about an area where we disagree and that
is on the veracity of the New Testament
versus the Old Testament so let's start
with some kind of the broader
philosophical framework what do you
think that Christianity adds to the
world that that Judaism didn't in the
first place first of all I want you to
know how proud I am to have friends like
you
and Dennis Prager Michael Medved I'll be
back with Dennis again I think I
remember Dennis's comment when we were
talking on this he was brilliant what he
said he said when Messiah comes I will
just have one question have you been
here before and I think that is what
it'll really boil down to I don't like
to say the word add because it seems
like it is something superimposed that
wasn't there I think it was already
there been of course my own upbringing
was so different it was America my
ancestors were Orthodox Hindu priests
generations who go from the highest
caste to the end of priesthood I think
it is that one verse one line that the
moral law hangs upon I am the Lord your
God the brought you out of the land of
Egypt that Redemption motif I think it
moved beyond the metaphor from Egypt
although it was real it moved beyond the
blood sacrifices and it moved the very
person of the son of man that Daniel
talked about and the perfection of the
law which was not violated but affirmed
and endorsed so what I see it the person
of Jesus Christ are two very real things
Ben number one it is the fact that he
embodied that which was the purest that
was called for by this very rigorous 613
system of laws that were given and if
you move down even to come back
ah which is then quoted three times in
the New Testament from 613 David reduced
it to a handful Isaiah reduced it even
more Micah brought it down to three to
do justice to love mercy and to walk
humbly before you God
but the Habakkuk phrase of the just
shall live by faith which I understand
is more correctly represented as by his
faithfulness you know that when you move
into the person of Christ two things
happen
the law is honored and not debunked but
the relationship question you know when
you give the four propositions in your
closing chapter you know starting all
the way from purpose and then the in
relationship the most moving woman in
your book is when you talk to your
daughter okay I loved it I'm a
grandfather of five and my grandson Jude
brilliant guy he uses words like
hypothesis and all of that is only about
his turning eight tomorrow okay when my
daughter Naomi lost her car keys she
stopped going crazy in the house slapped
her forehead and said I must be losing
my mind
little Judah was five and a half men
stood in front of her he said mommy what
have you new please don't ever lose your
heart because I'm in there
that personal relationship as much as I
value and love the law I need to go
beyond that relationships and so here's
what I say the most beautiful moment in
the New Testament to me if I were to
choose one moment or two first I would
want listen to Jesus's talk on Emmaus
Road because he connects all the gods
going back to the beginning
brilliant history lesson you would love
it I think as he talked on the miswrote
but the second moment was when he is on
the Mount of Transfiguration who does he
bring with him Moses and Elijah two of
the most thundering prophets for whom he
was the Undertaker okay we don't know
exactly what Moses was buried in Elijah
goes up on chariots of
fire but then he goes to the cross I
know I can't pay for myself the
redemptive factor of the purest paying
for the impure not that there was no
penalty but he paid it and then rises
again from the dead to me it's a
composite that doesn't violate what
preceded I think it completes it and to
me the attractiveness and I really
appreciate you even giving me the
opportunity to share it let me give you
an illustration of this I was in
Jerusalem some years ago you may know
the name of moisture on the well-known
scholar and Islamics in Israel okay I
was writing a book on an imaginary
conversation would be Jesus environment
he'd be released posthumously so I'll
tell you what he said to me great man
he's probably more written more on a
knee and scripture and stone than any
other human being around he looked at me
and you said Mr Zechariah as you're a
very clever man he said I'll tell you
something you don't know I said there's
a lot I don't know sir said let me tell
you something he said you don't know
about me
he said I'm now a professor he said but
I used to work for the Mossad he said Mr
Dyk rise you're a Christian I'm a Jewish
man should we both have one thing in
common I said what's that
he said communion with God I said you're
right
my goal in life is to have communion
with God he said so mine said but I
picked up extremists who would go and
blow themselves up and what people don't
know he said they would have a legend
good leather lend girdle around that
midsection so that they could protect
what they felt they were going to use in
paradise finally so that's a different
worldview that's a different worldview
he said you and I can talk because we
have the same goal communion with God
but if a person thinks of an erotic and
essentially driven eternity I'm not on
the same page but that person we have
completely different goals
so I say
to me in Christ I see the completion of
the story because I hunger not just for
propositional truth when Jesus comes
down from the mountain and Peter goes
what does he say but now we have the
word of the prophets made most certain
and you will do well to pay heed to it
as a light in a dark place so I think it
is a completion and my friend Prager was
absolutely right when the Lord returns
I'll say surely have you been but my
goal would be to get there before he
returns I'm 73 that's why so I do want
to ask you you know the one of the
issues that then now comes up routinely
and you know I start with my book I know
that you've experienced it as well as if
you mentioned judeo-christian
civilization if you mentioned Western
civilization there's a whole school of
thought out there now that this is
effectively just a form of racism that
this is a form of white supremacy which
comes I think is an ironic accusation
toward both you and toward me but that
that attempt to paint the even the term
judeo-christian civilization is
inherently exclusive do you think that
is it reflects any accuracy in other
words what distinguishes the
judeo-christian worldview from some of
the other religious worldviews you
mentioned early on that when you have
debates with folks or discussions with
folks who are of other monotheistic
faith that those tend to be some of the
hardest conversations where do you think
that the judeo-christian worldview
diverges from some of the other faiths
with what you've discussed you know I
think we're also paying the penalty of
our flaws historically the church has
made huge blunders you point out some of
this in your book as well how do we hide
from that what it really showed and even
the way they handled scientific progress
at times which is not well done it
actually ends up proving the depravity
of man it doesn't prove who Jesus is
what the Bible actually teaches but it
proves what we become as human beings
when we are when we give to ourselves
power over everybody else so I say we
have to own up our mistakes but we have
no more mistakes made than those who are
over countable
which are the two most rogue regimes in
the world today if you go back to the
20th century more people were killed in
communist countries than any Democratic
couple a capitalistic system put
together and you know that well you put
the slaughter of people between China
and Russia alone and then you bring in
Vietnam and Cambodia I was in Vietnam in
the 70s not as a fighter but as a
working with the chaplains I was only in
my 20s I saw what was happening I was in
Vietnam a few weeks ago and they
themselves talk about what is being done
to them under this heavily atheistic
regime the fact of the matter is to
point this finger against those of a
judeo-christian worldview shows a
prejudice that is not in keeping with
history why is it people come to the
shores of this country okay I came here
when I was 20 years old came through
legally came through though going
through the hoops came through answering
questions because we saw some ethical
norms here and less corruption in the
political process than from whence my
brother and I were coming he was 22 and
I was 20 and the fact of the matter is
people don't realize it was the bequest
of that Sharia Christian framework when
China before this particular one was
quite demagogic was starting to send
their scholars over to hear you talk to
almost any Chinese at that time you know
what he would say we were thinking of
why is this country so ethically driven
and has the values of human life
contrary to mind when Tocqueville came
whom you mentioned - What did he say
that there were people of faith we are
now throwing out that which and
engendered our values and now we think
we can have values without that
foundation yes the mistakes have been
made but greater mistakes have been made
by those who denied the existence of God
every one of us believes in God every
one the only difference where they
believe in the real God or end up
defying ourselves okay now what about
the other perspectives
especially the pantheistic worldview one
famous Indian polity
just recently wrote in The Wall Street
Journal that we give freedom to whatever
you want to believe and go on and on
well that's very noble if that is the
case but then we should revisit that and
talk about should we be making anti
conversion laws then if we make anybody
give people the freedom to believe why
then I'll be barricading anybody who
wants to choose otherwise so we have to
think these things through and so what I
say is we ought to give people the
freedom to believe or to disbelieve and
we do not what not to have a theocracy
because dictating religious belief is
the best way to kill that belief as
Europe finally evicted you know the
priest and the King as it were so I
believe you give the freedom to believe
in the biggest place we need to be given
this privilege is on in our academic
institutions
if universities would open their door to
intelligent dialogue with our
differences I believe things will change
it is the fact that they have blocked
out a prejudicial description of what
the judeo-christian worldview is all
about think of it this way and the
judeo-christian worldview is raining
yeah we had our views on sexuality but
we weren't sending people to jail or the
whole process now in relativism horse
way we are bringing everybody out of the
woodwork and what they did 20 30 40
years ago because of us on to see them
in jail it just goes to show you that
what you said earlier we all have our
absolutes we only bring them out when it
serves our own purposes it is not the
judeo-christian worldview that is to
blame it is the way some people use
their belief that I think engenders this
kind of prejudicial reaction so in one
second don't ask your final question
don't ask why secularism seems to be and
is statistically in the ascendancy given
the fact that there are all sorts of
internal contradictions in this
philosophy I want to ask that final
question but if you want to hear Ravi
Zacharias is answer you actually have to
be a daily wire subscriber to subscribe
head on over to daily we're calm click
Subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation over there O'Reilly that
Christ it's really an honor for you to
be here and I really appreciate your
time sir thank you so much and Godspeed
god bless God bless you been so nice to
meet you thanks for the freighter
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jesuit alvera
title graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]